Hello everybody, it's Dr. Kevin Cutters, and this is a question that we've gotten for years.
Can I just buy a program knife without becoming a full patient of yours and doing all the testing?
Maybe you don't have that much money. Maybe you're trying to figure out how to be able to best take care of yourself on a little bit tighter budget.
Well, even a program knife is still expensive. I understand that. It may be outside of some people's budgets.
And I don't know what else I can do for that personnel.
But we often just told people to go to true knife and buy a knife from them.
Now, I have certain criteria when you're buying a knife machine. It has to be has enough power to be able to penetrate your body.
It has to be using light frequencies. It has to be programmable so that I can run the frequencies from my cancer or my disease.
And then it has to be hardy and easy to use for a person, not have to fix all the time and not have issues where it's difficult to actually use, and therefore the person doesn't use it.
Well, we've settled on the true knife brand. You go to their website. I have no financial ties to them or anything.
But we use those for all of our patients. And that's the ones that I program to sell with my program on it.
That's what we're going to talk about here because it's one thing buying a knife machine and then, well, no, what programs do I run for my cancer? I got breast cancer. What am I supposed to use?
Well, with our patients, we test with the cheek swab and do that sort of test to get specific with their cancers. But I have programmed, I've written rice programs for 20 years now.
And I have specific programs for just about every type of cancer there is. There's a few that I've never seen before and never helped somebody with.
That might be an odd one that I'll have to go back to the drawing board and figure out. But most of the cancers out there I've written programs for.
And I'm basically selling program right through this. So I want people to be able to get those general programs.
They're very specific in one sense too so that you can run it. My philosophy with using the knife is that you're using it at night while you're sleeping.
Now, I do put on their day programs too for you to use too. So understand you can't do it during the day.
We have some patients that are doing it basically 24-7 because they're not ambulatory. But I want people, if you're healthy enough to be out guarding, they're out working with your kids or grandkids and stuff and want you to be doing that.
That's our philosophy of care. We want you to be functioning and doing life and living life than what you're supposed to be doing.
So yes, we can program a right for you. We need to stay within our scope. We're not treating cancer. This doesn't treat cancer. This doesn't cure anybody. This is not a magic wand.
You have to understand those parameters. It's a tool. Just like any other tool. You use it correctly and it can help your body. It can help your body possibly stimulate your immune system to be able to fight a disease.
That's our idea with right frequencies. Everything known with smallest particles of frequency that's vibrating energy that's vibrating in a specific frequency, so as cancer, so as any disease.
If you hit it with that frequency, your body can recognize it and possibly destroy it. That's the whole idea with right. I would personally never try to treat cancer myself without using a right.
My experience with right with my cancer has been amazing. So that's why we want to get right a right machine into everybody's hand who has a serious disease.
So we don't want you to be ignorant though. So we want you to do your research either on this course. I put a bunch of right videos and we can add in stuff all the time.
To come back and look at it. Also go to our website. There's a bunch of right information in the course of our book. There's information on the right too. So educate yourself.
So you're not getting into this thinking wrongly about what a right is. So I don't ever want people to be misinformed.
That's why we have these educational videos and sites. So with our package, you get the true right. The F122 package has the F122 generator.
That's the right machine itself. That's the thing in the center here. You get the crystal hammer ball, which you can't see because it's tucked into the foam there.
But it's about a 15 inch tube that's crystallized. That's encased in plexiglass. So you really can't break it. It's very difficult to break. You have to try to break it to break it.
And that's what the treatment comes through. That's what the frequencies are coming through that light bulb that's then going through your body.
You get the iron pro wave, which is a foot bath detoxer and where you could get different higher frequencies through that water, through that medium.
And it comes with a grouting mat. And you get a PC laptop that's shown here. We vary different types of PCs that we could get to be able to program.
So it comes with the right program, the version six program on it. And it also comes with your particular program. So let's say you have breast cancer.
You'll have breast cancer folder on the right machine in that folder. We'll have some iron pro wave programs and seven nightly programs.
They'll be listed one Sunday, two Monday, three Tuesday, and so forth because that's again our philosophy. Treat yourself while you're sleeping.
You can run those programs during the day, but they're eight or nine hour programs. Also, most of them have one or two day programs that you can run as well.
So if you're going to sit and watch a movie or something, you can run the day program. It's maybe an hour to three hours long and you can run those as well.
And then it also comes with about 2400 other programs for just about every different disorder you can possibly think of.
And it should be your go to to let's say you have a sore throat, you can run the strap program or something like that.
Use this right if you're never going to wear it out. I have one at home at this recording that's probably 12 years old.
Another one that's about three years old. And I use it every night. So the great tool.
And you know, we want to educate you with it. Also on the laptop, we put some educational videos for you to help understand how to use it to make it very clear for you to use as well.
So we're here to pray with you. We're here to talk with you. We're here to educate you. That's what this course is for is for education.
Understand, we're not treating disease or giving medical advice. You need to talk to your doctor about that. So again, I hope this is a benefit to you.
Continue to dig into the information and there'll be links on where you can purchase the right through our store. All right, bye bye.